لا يحتاج إيلون ماسك إلى تعريف، فهو
أغنى شخص في العالم، وهو شخصية مثيرة للخلاف،
وشرير للبعض وعبقري للبعض
الآخر، وهو في طليعة
حركة السيارات الكهربائية، والسفر عبر الفضاء،
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، والآن
الذكاء الاصطناعي جنبًا إلى جنب مع شركات التكنولوجيا
الثقيلة الأخرى، انضم رئيس تيسلا إلى
اجتماع مع قادة الكونجرس في
واشنطن يوم الأربعاء لمناقشة
مخاطر وفرص الذكاء الاصطناعي، ها هو
المسك يغادر الاجتماع،
أعتقد أن هناك شيئًا جيدًا سنغطيه هذا،
أعتقد أن هذا هذا الاجتماع، أتمنى من الله أن
يكون التاريخ مهمًا جدًا
لمستقبل الحضارة  السبب
وراء كوني مدافعًا عن سلامة الذكاء الاصطناعي
قبل حدوث أي شيء
فظيع هو أنني أعتقد أن عواقب
حدوث خطأ في الذكاء الاصطناعي ستكون وخيمة،
لذا يتعين علينا أن نكون استباقيين بدلاً
من رد الفعل، فهناك احتمال أن يكون ذلك
أعلى من الصفر  أعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي سيشعر بالتحسن
وأعتقد أنه منخفض ولكن في هذه الفرصة
أعتقد أنه يعتبر أيضًا
هشاشة الحضارة الإنسانية، الحضارة الإنسانية
بالفعل ومثل العديد من
المليارديرات الأقوياء، يجد ماسك
نفسه أيضًا مستعدًا وقادرًا على التأثير على
السياسة حتى الحرب زميلنا والتر
إيزاكسون  قضيت عامين في تتبعه
والنتيجة هي سيرة ذاتية مكونة من 670 صفحة
والتي من المؤكد أنها تصنع الأمواج كما
ناقشنا هنا في نيويورك،
مرحبًا بك والتر إيزاكسون، شكرًا لك في برنامجنا،
لذا فأنت هنا تقوم بتأليف
سيرة ذاتية عبقرية أخرى، ما الذي يميز إيلون
ماسك؟  لقد أثار مخيلتك حقًا
هذا جيدًا عندما بدأت لأول مرة،
كان هو الشخص الوحيد القادر على إرسال
رواد فضاء أمريكيين إلى المدار منذ أن
تم إيقاف تشغيل المكوك الفضائي،
وكان يفعل أكثر من أي شخص آخر
لإيصالنا إلى هواء
المركبات الكهربائية لإنشاء البطاريات  لإنشاء
أسطح شمسية لذلك اعتقدت أنه كان يقوم بهذه
المهام الملحمية بالطبع في
المنتصف بعد عام أو نحو ذلك من الإبلاغ،
قرر البدء بهدوء في شراء
تويتر، لذا أصبح الأمر أكثر من مجرد
رحلة أفعوانية، كما كشف أيضًا عن
كل من محركات الأقراص التي تأتي  في رأسه
ولكن الشياطين التي تكون أحيانًا مظلمة وأحيانًا
يمكنه توجيهها إلى محركات الأقراص،
ما الذي فكرت فيه وماذا
خرجت،
اعتقدت في البداية أنه كان
تقنيًا لديه شعور جيد حقًا
بالتصنيع وكيفية صنعه  المصانع
أيضًا أنه كان مجازفًا ورجلًا في
هذا البلد، وفي الواقع اعتدنا في كل الغرب
أن نكون أكثر مجازفين، كما تعلم،
كل من جاء إلى الولايات المتحدة
جاء سواء كان ماي فلاور عبر
النهر الكبير يتحمل بعض المخاطر ولكن
الآن لدينا حكام أكثر من
المجازفين، كما تعلم أن لدينا
محامين ومنظمين أكثر من
المبتكرين، لذلك اعتقدت أنه حسنًا
يدفع الأمور إلى الأمام ولكن يجب أن
أرى أيضًا أن هذا قد يكون نوعًا من الظلام في
بعض الأحيان يمكن أن يكسره  الأشياء التي يمكنها
تفجير الصواريخ ومن ثم
يمكنها بالطبع تعطيل تويتر، لذا فهي تدور حول
قصة عن شخص يمثل
نسيجًا محكمًا من قوة الضوء والظلام